you've got a good birthday coming up uh
later it's the big for you the big Trio
I love my 30s yeah yeah I know you
always talk about yourself my 20s were
hard really yeah because I was lonely I
didn't have a band
I was lonely so much fun here I love my
band it's hard like when you're in the
spot like that to like you know just
communicate what that's like so I was
yeah 20s were hard but 30s were cool
you're gonna love it my 20s were fun I
had a great time
um whatever Nile
I was no I was having a great time in my
20s I really enjoyed it um do you freak
out about age are you freaking out about
it no I'm one of those people I couldn't
care less honestly I like everybody
talks about the 30s being the new 20s so
yeah I'm up for um
feel older my hangovers are worse harder
very long your knees as well you know
what I mean the knees I know soccer is
hard on you yeah it is
um but no I'm looking forward to it I
um my best friend since I was like three
years old his parents and my parents
were in the same class at school we were
in the same class at school his name is
Molly and um I'm sorry Molly from
mullinger
Holland like the street here
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah and we're he's like five weeks six
weeks older than me okay and we're gonna
do a joint 30th because I hate 30th
used to be over here after 13 years no
13. 13 after 13 years I still think it's
funny
um no so what are y'all gonna you're
gonna be doing
I don't like
the last time I celebrated her birthday
was 21 went to Vegas did the whole the
whole deal that was yeah that was big
and then I haven't celebrated really
since I'm not really a birthday guy but
30 of them definitely going to do really
the 30th one yeah um so please I'm gonna
keep doing it awesome I love it so wait
why don't you don't like so you like
just being low-key I don't know I just
I'd go for a few drinks with a few mates
or yeah make sure that there's no case
don't like surprises I hate surprises I
hate them yeah um and I also don't like
pressure to have to be like I love that
yeah yeah yeah so don't do that if
you're going to surprise me I did hear
that you don't like when people sing
Happy Birthday to you so I'm totally
gonna get Shelton to do that for me on
video to send it oh I don't mind it like
if it's been sent to me or whatever but
if you know when you're in a room
the whole room is looking at you and
it's like a 40 second Spiel compliment
thing yeah don't doesn't that happen
like every time you end a song on like
the stage
I guess so yeah it's a different thing
don't you hate when people just sit
there and adore you but you can't just
like you can't stop it's not like you
can clap along yeah it's not like you
sing along to your own birthdays um yeah
I know you yeah I would
um and yeah I've just never been I've
never been a fan of the birthday thing
but uh okay duly noted yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]